[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله اهلا بكم معكم
محمد كريشان وهذه التغطيه مباشره للتصعيد
غير المسبوق بين مجموعه فاجنر والقياده
العسكريه الروسيه قائد مجموعه العسكريه
الروسيه الخاصه
للحشد لمواجهه القاده العسكريين الروس
بعدما اتهم وزير الدفاع الروسي باعطاء
اوامر لقصف قواته في احد معسكراتها
باوكرانيا ونشر بريكوجين ما قال انها صور
للقصف مشيرا الى انه اسفر عن مقتل عدد ضخم
من قواته وتوعد قائد بالرد مشيرا الى ان
ما يقوم به ليس انقلابا عسكريا وانما
مسيره لتحقيق العداله على حد تعبيره في
المقابل نفت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قصف
قوات فاجنر ووصفت هذا الادعاء بالاستفزاز
الاعلامي بينما قال ان بوتين مطلع على
التطورات المتعلقه ويتم اتخاذ جميع
التدابير اللازمه
معنا من اوسكو مدير مكتبنا زاور شاور زاور
التفاعلات في موسكو لكل هذه التطورات
نعم بدون شك في البدايه محمد هذا تطور
خطير في مسيره العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا مسيره هذه الحرب ما يجري
اليوم هو ربما تراكم لاشهر من السجال
الكلامي على الاقل من طرف واحد من قبل
مالك شركه فاجنر باتجاه قائد الاركان
باتجاه وزير الدفاع الروسي والقيادات
العسكريه التي اتهمها بانها كانت فاشله في
اداره هذه الحرب وانهم انهما تحديدا دراسه
يتحملان مسؤوليه الخسائر العسكريه الروسيه
الكبيره لما وصفه بانه فشل في اداره هذه
الحرب وعدم الاهليه
والفساد بهذه العبارات
هذين الشخصيين وهما اعلى مركزين قياديين
عسكريين اليوم كان هناك
تصريح مسجل صباحا كانت فيه شده الاتهامات
كبيره ولكن مساء
تقريبا ساعه ونصف من الان جاءت الاخبار
ونتحدث عن اللسان فريجوجل تحديدا من طرف
وزاره الدفاع هناك فقط نفي لكل ما يروج له
ان القوات الروسيه باستخدام
المروحيات وباستخدام المدفعيه استهدفت
المعسكرات الداخليه لقوات باقدر التي
انسحبت من باخت من اجل اعاده التجهيز
استعدادا للذهاب الى معركه اخرى مما ادى
الى مقتل
عشرات حسب قوله من قوات فاكيد ولكن الخطير
هو اعلان
انه بعد الاجتماع بقياده القوات التي تتبع
له قوات تم اتخاذ القرار بالذهاب باتجاه
شيقو وباتجاه غراسي ماذا يعني هذا محمد
نحن نعلم ان قياده القوات العسكريه
الروسيه التي تقوم او تدير العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا موجوده في مدينه
روستوف احدى اكبر المدن الروسيه في جنوب
روسيا التي تقع على حدود دومباس واي منطقه
العسكريه تاريخيا معروفه بانها احدى اهم
مراكز
القدرات العسكريه الروسيه وانا احذر من ان
يحاول احد ايقاف هذه الجموع التي تتجه
سماها قوه تكتيكيه مكونه من 25 الف عسكري
مسلح من قوات فاجنر قال ان هذا هذه القوه
هي القوه التكتيكيه ولكن يوجد عمق
استراتيجي من قبل يمكن ان يمد هذه القوه
ان كان من قبل القوات الروسيه على حد
يتعبدها او من الشعب الروسي الذي يريد ان
يضع حدا لما سماه
بالفشل والاوضاع التي وصلت اليها البلاد
في اطار العمليه العسكريه والخسائر
الكبيره التي تتعرض لها القوات الروسيه
بدون شك هذا تطور خطير محمد لا يمكن ان
يوصف بشكل او باخر سوى انه تمرد على
القرارات العسكريه وكما نعلم روسيا دوله
مركزيه القرار مركزيه فيما يتعلق
بالقرارات السياسيه والقرارات العسكريه
كان يثير الجدل كثيرا صمت بوتين عن هذا
السجال دائم وانتقادات الدائمه من بريجوجل
بريجوجل لم يطل ابدا شخصيه الرئيس الروسي
ولكن ما يمكن ان نفهمه اليوم هو ان انه
بتصريح الكرمله المقتضى بان الرئيس الروسي
على اطلاع عما يجري الان وانه تتخذ
الاجراءات اللازمه اذا هذا الموضوع صدر
قبل قليل بيان لجنه مكافحه الارهاب
الروسيه الفيدراليه التي فتحت قضيه
تجاهها تصريحات وقرار قائد قوات بتحريك
القوات على الارض وايضا دعته الى اتوقف
على خارق القانون وبالتالي هذه الهيئه
الفيدراليه لا يمكن ان تتخذ اي قرار بهذا
الشكل دون اخذ بعين الاعتبار
القرار السياسي في الكرملين يمكن فهم اقول
هنا يمكن فهم ما يجري الان ان الرئيس
البوتين ويقف الى جانب وزير الدفاع وقائد
الاركان ولكن كما قلت احب واريد ان اركز
على هذه النقطه محمد
[موسيقى]
تحرير قوات على الجبهات ولكن اليوم الحديث
عن اتهامات مباشره هناك في استخدام نوع من
اللغه المنخفضه اخلاقيا ان صح التعبير بحق
قائد الاركان وبحق وزير الدفاع الروسي
وهذا امر لم تعتمد عليه روسيا في تاريخها
محمد مزاور طبعا ستبقى معنا وينضم الينا
الان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي وسانطلق مما قاله زاور قبل
قليل وهو استعمال كلمه او مفرده التمرد
اذا سلمنا بانه تمرد عسكري فعلا ما الذي
يمكن ان ينجر عنه
يعني اذا كان التمرد في اي دوله في العالم
وخاصه كدوله مثل روسيا
تتميز بالنظام المركزي يجب احتواء هذا
التمرد ويجب انهائه والقضاء عليه وبالتالي
تاريخيا
التربيه العسكريه منذ ما قبل الثوره
البلشفيه ومنذ زمن الجيش الابيض ومن ثم
الجيش الاحمر بعد الثوره الفلسفيه
ومرورا في فترات تستالين وما بعدت هناك
نوع من العنف المفرط في التعامل مع هكذا
احداث وبيت سيبيريا تشهد على عمليات
التهجير القسري ليس فقط لمن يرتكب الجرم
انما لعائلته ومنطقته وبالتالي اذا كان
هذا الادعاء صحيح وان تحريك القوات باتجاه
روستوف وغير ذلك وثبت ان هناك نوا تمرد
حقيقي لابد من احتوائه ولابد من التعامل
معه بجديه الان العلاقه الشخصيه ما بين
بجوجن والرئيس بوتين وطباخ بوتين
ودعوات الزعامات عالميه الى سلسله مطاعمه
اعتقد لا ترقى او لا تقف هذه هكذا علاقه
في وجه تحدي خطير في وقت خطير على على
القوات المسلحه الروسيه اذا دعني اقول هو
لا يقول بالانقلاب يقول بتصحيح المسار
ولكن ما معنى تصحيح هذا المسار هل هو بصدد
فرض املاءات على الكرملين ان تغير
القيادات العسكريه التي هو لا يرتاح
للتعامل معها واتهمها بامور كثيره اعتقد
ان هذا الطلب اكثر مما يقبل او اكثر مما
يعتمل ولكن كان ملفتا في البيان نقطه
عندما قال
عدد القوات 25 الف ماذا قصد بذلك البعض
فسرها على انها نوايا من اجل تنفيذ انقلاب
انا افسرها بمقاربه مختلفه كليا هناك
تقارير واضحه ان عدد قوات فاجنر 50 الف
وصل 50 الف الان يتحدث عن 25 الف فكانه
يخاطب ويقول انا قدمت 50% من قواتي
لمعالجه فشل شويغو وفاليري وبالتالي من
يقدم 50% هذا ابن الوطن يدافع عن الوطن
هذا يسهر على حمايه الامن الوطني انا قدمت
50% من حجم القوه قتلوا لتسكير الثغرات
بسبب فشل شويغو وفاليري فبالتالي هو كانه
استخدم انا احلل كانه استخدم هذا الرقم
ليقنع بوتين بمصداقيه توجهه وبانه وطني
ولكن هذه الجماعه هي تعيق العمل هي ورطتك
يا الرئيس بوتين في حرب خاسره قدموا لك
التقارير بان العمل سينتهي خلال اسبوع الى
عشره ايام والان مره اكثر من 16 شهرا ولا
نزال في الوحي الاوكراني ولولا قوات فاجنر
لما لما تم استعاده السيطره على سوليدار
اذا اردنا ان نعرف على الصعيد العسكري
وناخذ الكلمتين بمسافه وبنوع من التحفظ
التمرد والانقلاب في الحاله الاوكرانيه
وفي الحاله الروسيه الان ما الذي يمكن ان
يعنيه هذا وما الذي يمكن ان يعنيه ذاك
يا سيدي عندما نتحدث عن انقلاب نتحدث عن
اطاحه بالمنظومه السياسيه
وتغيير البنيه
والتركيبه
الكيميائيه للدوله تغيير نظام حكم عندما
نتحدث عن تمردنا نتحدث عن مطالب دون ذلك
ان تتمرد وحده عسكريه نتيجه ظروف قاهره
رفضا لواقع سيء وبالتالي هي لا تسعى
للاطاحه بنظام الحكم لا تسعى الى تغيير
كيميائيه الدوله ولكنها ترغب في تصحيح
مسار خاطئ بل انا ارى ان هناك فجو
من المقاربتين الانقلاب العسكري وما بين
التمرد ولكن كلا الامرين هو خروج على
القانون خروج على الدستور بغض النظر هذا
الدستور وهذه القوانين تلقى القبول او لا
تلقى لكن يبقى الدستور هو الكتاب المقدس
لاي دوره لاي دوله في المستوى الدنيوي
والوضعي ولكن عندما نتحدث عن تمرد عاده
نتحدث عن
قطاع معين من داخل المنظومه العسكريه
نفسها يعني مثلا عندما يصف الجيش السوداني
قوات الدعم السريع بانها متمرده على اساس
انها خرجت على المنظومه الامنيه والدفاعيه
بالنسبه للحاله الروسيه الان في اوكرانيا
هذه شركه خاصه يعني مقاول خاص ان صح
التعبير كيف له ان يتمرد على المؤسسه الام
المؤسسه العسكريه
يا سيدي حتى هذه حتى هذه المنظمه الخاصه
حتى يعني حتى القوات الدعم السريع ليست
موضوعنا وقد يكون لي اجابه اقول الان حتى
هذه المؤسسه الخاصه هي تم تاسيسها بناء
على شروط معينه
وتوظيف معين
ولتحقيق اهداف لكن قوات فاجنر قوات فاجنر
استخدمت الدوله الروسيه لتحقيق اهدافها
خارج الجغرافيا الروسيه فبالتالي نجدها
ذهبت الى سوريا
ذهبت الى مالي
ذهبت الى ليبيا
ذهبت الى السودان
ذهبت الى الكونغو وبالتالي اصبحت تحقق
موضع قدم للدوله الروسيه في هذه في هذه
الاماكن وكلنا نتذكر عندما ذهبوا الى
ليبيا كيف كان رد الافرام القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه الافريقيه وبالتالي
انتبهوا الى انها بدايه التمدد الروسي في
هذه المنطقه اذا هذا التنظيم او هذه
المنظمه الخاصه كانت بالتناغم ومن خلال
التوافق والتكليف تقوم بتنفيذ مهامات
اوليه
لا يستطيع الجيش الروسي بحكم التوازنات
الدوليه ان يقوم بها فكانت تذهب بحجه
حراسه مناجم الماس ومناجم الذهب وغير ذلك
ولكنها كانت تنزل
اجند او تهيئ لتنفيذ اجنده الجنسيه الان
اصبح لها وزنها بدات العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه بدات الانتكاسات في الجيش الروسي
حدثت في كييف في خار كيف في خرسون
وبالتالي كان لابد تم التعبئه الجزئيه
ورغم كل ذلك لم يستطع الجيش الروسي ان
ينجز ما هو مطلوب منه فماذا كان البديل
كان
وهذه فاغنر انعكاسات اعداد الخسائر من
قوات فاجنر اقل تاثيرا والى من على الشارع
الروسي من خساره 25 الف جندي على سبيل
المثال لماذا لان هؤلاء بعقود خاصه جاؤوا
بمل ارادتهم معظمهم اربعين الف منهم من
السجون اسبقيات الجرميه طلب منه انه تذهب
وتقاتل راس حربه لمده سته اشهر وتصبح الان
طليق وتذهب الى طي صفحه وبدا به صفحه
فبالتالي هؤلاء هم في الاصل جماعه خارجين
على القانون
الاجتماعي من خلال عمليات القتل والاغتصاب
والمخدرات ستبقى معنا
ينضم الينا الان من موسكو فاسيلي في
ديجاروف الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
والضابط الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد فاتيكارف
ما توصيفك لما جرى لحد الان
[موسيقى]
متاكد انها
عمليه استفزازيه واسعه وهذه الاستفزازات
بدات وستنتهي بالاستفزازات انها تصرفات
مدفوعه من العدو لان العدو فقط من تصب في
مصلحته نزع الاستقرار انا كعسكري شاهدت
المقاطع التي تظهر وكان احد من القوات
الروسيه قام بضربات على مواقع
فاكنار والعين العاديه ممكن ان تشهد ان
هذا كان عن امر مجهز كمسرحيه
شخص لا يخشى دون اي ذعر يجد جثث مقتوله
ويقول على الفور
استنتاجات ان هذه ضربات من الخلف لن
تسمعوا في المقاطع الا الصرخات والكلام
القبيح انها اعمال استفزازيه وهذا رسميا
يؤكد من وزاره الدفاع عنها اعمال
استفزازيه اذا انت تعتبرها عمليه
استفزازيه لم لم تصفها لا بالتمرد ولا
بالانقلاب ولكن عندما تقول مدفوعه من
العدو هل معنى ذلك بانها جرى ترتيبها مع
الاوكرانيين او مع النيتو او مع غيرهم
الامن الفيدراليه بدات في رفع دعوه قضائيه
وانا متاكد انه سوف يكون هناك رد رسمي على
هذا الوقت لا يزال قليل سوف نفهم جيدا من
يقف وراء هذه الاعمال هل هي المخابرات
الاوكرانيه او انها
الناتو فسوف نفهم هذا في اقرب وقت
في انتظار هذا الوقت القريب الذي تشير
اليه ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث الان وقد اهتزت
معنويات
المقاتلين الروس بشكل عام في الساحه في
اوكرانيا
المعنويات للقوات الروسيه قويه نحن
والاجزاء
المقاتله في فاقنر وقواتنا النظاميه كلنا
نحارب ضد عدو واحد ولا نبحث عن عدو داخلي
لدينا الاوضاع مستقره في المعنويات ونحن
نقاوم الهجمات العكسيه بهجمات عكسيه
ونتقدم في مارينكا وهذا واضح جيد جيدا على
كل ننوه لهذا التصريح الجديد من قائد
فاجنر يقول هذه الليله سنحل قضيه الخونه
والمجرمين الذين اهانوا روسيا وهما وزير
الدفاع ورئيسه هيئه الاركان هنا في هذه
الحاله سيد فادي كاروف هذا التركيز من
بريكوجين على وزير الدفاع وعلى رئيس
الاركان
ولكنه لا يتحدث عن غيرهما كيف تفسرهم
اعتقد ان الاستفزازات اؤكد على انها اعمال
استفزازيه منظمه بطريقه حيث
يتم تهيئ مجموعات خاصه العسكريين ضد
الاداره لهذا تسمى استفزازات ان اعمال
بريجوجل يتم تفتيش عنها وعليها الان قد
يكون احد قام بتضليل السيد بريجو جين وقام
برده فعل عاطفيه او ان هذه التسجيلات اصلا
مزيفه
سيد
ايضا تصريح جديد
قائد يقول بان
شويغو وزير الدفاع طبعا سيشنق هكذا يقول
سيشنق في الميدان الاحمر وسيدفن في الضريح
مع العينين
هذا ربما سيكون اكثر من عمليه استفزازيه
كما وصفت
صريحه لانني اعتقد وانا اعرف السيد يفقيني
ان الاعلانات لا معنى لها من هذا النوع هو
شيء من المستحيل ان يسبح به السيد يفقيني
لانه شخص وطني وقبل واعتقد ان هناك من
يضعه في فخ ويجب ان نقوم بالتعامل مع هذه
المعلومات التي لا تزال في فتره قصيره جدا
ستبقى معنا سيد باديجاروف ينضم الينا الان
العقيد الكسندر فواتير رئيس تحرير المجله
العسكريه السويسريه اهلا وسهلا بك
ما يحصل الان
في العلوم العسكريه وفي العلوم الحربيه
كيف يمكن ان يوصف
في الحقيقه هذا هو السؤال المطروح الان
بالنسبه الى
وجه
المرتبط
وبعدما جمعت مجموعه فاجنر حوالي اربعين
الف الى خمسين الف
عسكري وخسرت المجموعه نصف هؤلاء تقريبا
هناك الكثير من الاحباط بالنسبه الى قياده
هذه المجموعه العسكريه الخاصه وهذا ما تم
التعبير عنه بشكل متكرر في وجهه قياده
الجيش الروسي ما الذي يمكن ان يحدث الان
في قياده هذا الجيش في ضوء كل هذه
التصريحات الاستفزازيه بين قوسين كما
وصفها ضيفنا من موسكو
لكل تاكيدا نحن نشهد على تصعيد كيف لي ان
اعبر عن هذا اذا اول الكلمات او اولى
الكلمات غير المهدبه اذا صح التعبير بدات
منذ سته اشهر ولكننا عبرنا مراحل متعدده
من هذه العلاقه المتوتره ووصلنا الى هذه
المرحله التي تم تخطي فيها مستوى
التصريحات المقبوله
وبالنسبه الى ما يمكن ان يحصل على الارجح
امور سيئه يمكن ان تحصل للسيد بريجوجين
ولمجموعه فاجنر ولكن في الوقت نفسه على
المدى البعيد من الممكن ان بعض الافكار
التي عبر عنها
والانتقادات التي عبر عنها قد يظهر الزمن
انها
كانت حاضره
اليها بشكل متزايد بين اوساطي المجموعات
القوميه
الحكومه الروسيه وهو اشكاليه بالنسبه الى
النظام الروسي والرئيس فلادي يعني هذه
التداعيات السيئه على شخصيه بريكوجين من
قبيل ماذا مثلا
ان دوله روسيا
معروفه
منذ زمن
بالحوادث الحوادث حوادث السير حوادث
الوقوع او السقوط عن اعلى السلالم لن نعود
كثيرا بالزمن الى الوراء اذا قد يحصل معه
اي حادث مؤسف من هذا القبيل بالاضافه الى
التهديدات التي يتعرض لها
والانشطه الاقتصاديه التي يقوم بها حيث
اننا نتحدث عن الشركه يمكن ان تامم على
سبيل المثال او ان توكل لاشخاص اثرياء روس
موثوق بهم من قبل النظام الروسي كلها امور
يمكن ان يتعرض لها قائد
سيبقى معنا
ضيوفنا جميعا اذا قال بريكوجين قائد
مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه ان
ما يحدث في البلاد هو فوضى داعيا الجيش
والبلاد باسرها لمسائله المعنيين ووضع حد
للفوضى وفق تعبيره
عددنا 25 الفا لماذا في بلادنا هذه
التعديات 25 الف احتياطي تكتيكي اما
الاحتياط الاستراتيجي فيضم الجيش بكامله
والبلد كلها كل من يرغب في الانضمام
فلينضم لابد من وضع حد لهذه الفوضى
سيد فيبوسكو
يقول بان جزء من
الجيش الروسي يدعم هذا التوجه الذي يعبر
عنه اذا تاكد ذلك هل نحن فعلا امام
امكانيه انشقاقات داخل المؤسسه العسكريه
الروسيه
اريد ان اقول ان القوات الروسيه الفيدرا
المسلحه كانت ولا تزال وسوف تبقى متوحده
والجنود لا يقوم بالاعلان عن ارائهم او ان
يقوموا بتوجيها الاتهامات على العلن
للقياده العليا هذا شيء غير مسموح به سوف
ننظر بالاوضاع باهتمام وهذا تخصص
لجنه الامن الوطني وما يقوم به السيد
بريغوجين او ما يعلنه ولكن انقسام القوات
الروسيه الان شيء
غير جيد واعتقد انه مستحيل لدينا عدو واحد
ونحن جميعا كروس نحن الان نحارب هذا العدو
وننتصر في حربه ولكن السيد هل هل موسكو
الان في ورطه بمعنى انها جاءت بمجموعه على
اساس انها تساعدها في حربها في اوكرانيا
فاذا بها تصبح مشكله امامها
انا اعتقد ان مجموعه بريغوجين اي الشركه
الخاصه لن تصبح مشكله هناك اشخاص عاقلين
في هذه المجموعه واكثرهم هم من العسكريين
الخاصين بنا ونحن لا نقوم بتوجيه الاسلحه
على بعضنا البعض اذكر اننا عدونا واحد
ويجب علينا ان ننتصر عليه متوحدين ليس
هناك اي خيار اخر عند امام روسيا اسال
السيد في جناب طبعا ضيفنا من موسكو يستبعد
اي امكانيه لاي انشقاقات ولكن عندما نرى
ان
مازال يواصل ويقول
تلقينا من عديد من جنود الروس
رسائل شكر على ما قمنا به الا يمثل ذلك
بوادر لشيء ما داخل الجيش الروسي
لست متاكدا بالنسبه الى تفاصيل هذه
الرسائل من الجنود الروس ولكن بشكل عام في
روسيا ما يمكن ان نقوله ان العلاقه بين
الوحدات العسكريه المختلفه والقاده
العسكريين على اختلافهم لم تكن هذه
العلاقه وديه دائما
وتعاونيه بشكل مستمر بين الوحدات والكتائب
المختلفه بين المظليين والمشاه وحرس
الحدود والقوات الخاصه الروسيه لطالما
شهدت هذه العلاقات توترات في الماضي وبعض
هذه التوترات طفت الى السطح في خلال هذه
العمليه الخاصه كما يسموها عندما تحدث
بلبله من هذا القبيل اللواء فايز الدويري
كيف يمكن للمؤسسه العسكريه ان تتصرف
يعني الان الخلاف مع قمه الهرم في المؤسسه
العسكريه
مع وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
وبالتالي المناكفه هي مع القمه
الذي يساعد على احتواء المشكله
المستوى السياسي
يجب ان يكون هناك تصريح من
سيد الكرملين يجب ان يكون هناك موقف واضح
يضع النقاط على الحروف اذا اخذنا بتصريحات
هذه تجاوزت الاستفزازات
تجاوزت التمرد اتجهت باتجاه الاطاحه بنظام
السياسي عندما يتحدث عن شنق رئيس الاركان
ووزير الدفاع هذه الليله ستحسم الامور مع
الخونه هل يعني هذه العبارات عبارات
مفتوحه وتفسر من قبل المحللين كل حسب
قراءته لما وراء الكلمات لكن السؤال الاهم
هل يستطيع بريكوجن ان يترجم هذه التصريعات
الى واقع ملموس على الارض لا اعتقد ذلك
اذا هي تبقى في اطار التصريح
اكثر منها في اطار التطبيق لانه لا يمكن
في بنيه الجيش الروسي وعديد الجيش الروسي
الذي يزيد عن مليون و250 الف
ان يتم
اتخاذ او القيام بالقاع هكذا تصريحات
واسقاطها على ارض الواقع وبالتالي انا لا
اقول عنها فقط هي استفزاز يجب
المستوى السياسي والمستوى العسكري يجب ان
ياخذها على محور الجد وان ياخذها
بحرفيتها وبالتالي لابد الان انه يجري
هناك تفاعلات سواء في الكرملين او في
المستوى العسكري وفي وزاره الدفاع لاليه
احتواء هذه التصريحات والحيلوله دون
ترجمتها على ارض الواقع وان كنت اشك في
قدره بريكوجن على ترجمته
ستبقون جميعا معنا بعد اذنكم نعود مره
اخرى الى مدير مكتب الجزيره في موسكو
زاورشوج زاوره التصريحات متلاحقه من
بريكوجين ولكن في موسكو تقريبا عدا ما صدر
عن لجنه مكافحه الارهاب من من رفع قضيه
ضده لا شيء متوقع الى حد الان
بدون شك هناك توقعات ان يكون هناك كلام
للرئيس الروسي او تصدر قرارات حاسمه بوقف
هذا
هذا التصرف
صحى وصفه من قبل شركه فاقدر ولكن على صعيد
الميداني هناك جزئين الاول فيما يتعلق في
موسكو الاجواء هادئه نحن رصدنا ما يجري في
محيط وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وفي محيط وزاره
الدفاع ممنوع التصوير ولكن الحياه عاديه
تمام هدوء كامل ايضا نفس الوضع في محيط
الكريم ولكن فيما يتعلق في محور روستوف
ايضا من خلال اتصالاتنا لا توجد اي تحركات
عسكريه كبيره واضحه لقوات فاكتير باتجاه
مدينتي راستوف لحد الان الوضع هادئ تماما
ربما في طرقات اخرى قد تقوم
باستخدامها من اجل الوصول الى منطقه
الرسوب ولكن يجب محمد التوقف عند نقطه
اساسيه ان هناك حشود عسكريه كبيره في تلك
المنطقه ان توجهت قوات فاجر بالفعل الى
هذا هذه الخطوه التي اعلن عنها
بالوصول الى القياده العسكريه من اجل
انهاء او حسب موضوع قياده القوات العسكريه
مثلها الروسيه بدون شك هذا سيؤدي ما
نتابعه من خلال المراسلنا العسكريين الى
اصطدام هذا قد ياخذ الحرفي باتجاه اخر قد
يسبب في ارباك القوات الروسيه المتواجده
الان على خط الجبهه هناك ايضا انتقادات في
من قبل
المراسلين العسكريين لتصريحات بروج في
مساله تراجع القوات الروسيه اعتبروها انا
ليست دقيقه تماما لا يوجد تراجعات للقوات
الروسيه في
محورسون ودونيسك ما يجري الان يخشى
الكثيرون هنا على الاقل من التحليلات
السياسيه الاولى التي صدرت ان الخلاف
الشخصي بين شيجو
وجراثيم في جهه وبريجوجن يتحول الان الى
الميدان هذا الخلاف بدا من سوريا منذ ان
قامت قوات بمحاوله السيطره على احد على
المشاهده النفطيه في دير الزور
[موسيقى]
بانه اعطى الضوء الاخضر للامريكيين لضرب
قواته وخسرت قوات في عام 2016 اكثر من 400
مقاتل منذ ذلك الحين هناك خلاف بين
الطرفين الان الكل ينظر الى الكرملين ينظر
الى بوتين ينتظر ما سيقوله
الشخصيه التي تعتبر شيكو يدها اليمين
وتعتبر بريجوجل يدها اليسرى
لم ينتقد في لحظه من اللحظات الرئيسه
الروسي هو قال انه على تواصل دائما مع
الرئيس الروسي يعتبره انه الرمز الذي يمكن
ان يعيد روسيا مجلها شيكوه وصديق الرئيس
الروسي مقرب له وبوتين يثق به بشكل كبير
وبالتالي الان المعضله هي كيف سيستطيع
بوتين ان يحل هذا الخلاف ان يخرج هذه
الازمه من مستواها الميداني وسياسي في ظرف
معقد تماما من على كل النواحي العسكريه
والسياسيه وحتى
في اطار المزاج العامل يعني هذا ينعكس
بشكل او باخر على مزاج الشارع نعم الشارع
ربما لا توجد احصاءات رسميه روسيا لا توجد
فيها مؤسسات
كشف رايه او رصد راي عام مستقله اما تابعه
الى الولايات المتحده وبالتالي لا يوجد
مراكز رصد لنعرف حقيقه راي الشارع ولكن
بدون شك هناك من خلال المتابعات انا ما
يجري بين
وقياده الجيش ينعكس بشكل او باخر بشكل
سلبي على المزاج العام لشارع روسي وايضا
بدون شك لا يوجد رضا كامل على اداء القوات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بسبب ارتفاع عدد
القتلى المتواصل رغما قلته مقارنه عما كان
عنه عنه في بدايه الحرب على الاقل هكذا ما
تقول المصادر على العسكريه وما تقول وزاره
الدفاع الروسيا ولكن بالعموم هذا مشهد
ننتظر ربما الساعات القادمه ننتظر ما
سيقول بوتين هل سيكون حاسما في هذا
الموضوع حتى لو كان حاسما في هذا الموضوع
ما جرى اليوم يبقى يطرح سؤالا مهما ما هو
مصير شركه فاجنر هل ستغادر فاجر بهذه
القوه العسكريه لتعود الى القاره
الافريقيه
حيث جاءت من هناك انا اختلف مع بعض الضيوف
بانهم غالبيتهم من المساجين لهذا الكلام
ليس دقيقه تماما غالبيه المقاتلين جاؤوا
من القاره الافريقيه همد عساكر وجنود
سابقون ما تم جلبهم من السجون تم ايقافه
بقرار بناء الرئيس الروسي وذلك خشيه من
اجل
الحفاظ على الامن داخل
البلاد ونعم خسر عدد كبير من هؤلاء
ارواحهم في المعارك ولكن
[موسيقى]
التصدي لهذه القوه هذا هذه هذه المعركه
طاحنه ستكون بدون شك كما قلت الانظار الان
متوجهه الى
الرئيس الروسي كيف سيحسم هذه المواجهه كيف
ستتوقف هذه هذا التصعيد الذي سيترك ان خرج
عن السيطره بدون شك هذا الموضوع سيترك
بدون شك له تداعيات كبيره ان كانت على
القوات العسكريه الروسيه كانت على على
ويبقى سؤال ما هو مصير فاجنر في نهايه هذه
المواجهه ان كانت لم تتطور الى امواج
عسكريه او تطورات الى مواجهه العسكريه
واضح ان فاجنر هنا في هذه الايام او
الساعات القادمه ستحسم قصتها بشكل او باخر
هل ستعود الى افريقيا هل ستلغى نهائيا ام
يجعل القضاء عليها نعم أحمد زاور ستبقى
معنا بطبيعه الحال نعود لضيفنا في موسكو
السيد
باديكوجين مازال مستمر في تصريحاته
نرحب
بامكانيه ان ينضم الينا اخرون في اشاره
عناصر من الجيش الروسي طبعا هنا السؤال
سيد هل موسكو
وقعت في
مشكل لم تكن تقدره من قبل وهي ان فاجنر
كانت تساعدها في سوريا ساعدتها في ليبيا
قامت بادوار عديده في افريقيا ولكنها لم
تكن تتخيل ان تنقلب عليها في اوكرانيا في
معركه تخص روسيا مباشره هذه المره
ولا في اي حاله من الاحوال لن تقوم ضد
القوات العسكريه النظاميه ان الحديث هنا
عن عمليات استفزازيه حاده جدا
اهدافها هي
اضعاف
الاوضاع الروسيه للقوات النظاميه وانا
اعتقد ان من يعمل في قوات باغنر هم جنود
روس سابقين وهؤلاء الضباط والجنود لن
يسبحوا لانفسهم ان يحملوا السلاح ضد
اخوانهم في السلاح امام قله الضيف من
سويسرا انه قال انه كان يعلم عن اختلافات
بين مختلف القوات الروسيه هذا شيء غير
حقيقي على ارض المعركه نحن موحدين موحدين
في اهداف واحده ولا احد
يقوم بمنافسه الاخر يجب علينا ان ننتصر
نسال ضيفنا في جنيف سيد
بالتاكيد الحلف الاطلسي الان يتابع هذه
التطورات ربما
بابتسامه خفيفه هل يمكن ان يستفيد النيتو
من هذا الذي يجري
لست متاكدا كيف يمكن لحلف شمال الاطلسي ان
يستفيد من هذه الوضعيه الخطره والمحفوفه
بالمخاطر عدد كبير من البلدان المنضويه
تحت لواء حلف شمال الاطلسي لم يتوقع هذا
الكم من التصريحات وايضا من قبل النزاع
الذي نشب وبالتالي هناك واقع يتعين على
دول النيتو ان تتعامل معه لذلك تعمل على
تعزيز التعاون الدفاعي وهو ما ادى ايضا
الى تسريع عمليه التعاون وتعزيز
القوات المسلحه في البلدان مختلفه وخصوصا
ايضا نعرف ما حصل بالنسبه الى طلبي فنلندا
والسويد الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلس
ولكن على الارض
هذا الذي جرى الليله كيف يمكن ان ينعكس في
سير المعارك في الايام المقبله على الاقل
سوفارديز حتى اللحظه الراهنه هذه
التصريحات لم تؤثر بشكل كبير على ميدان
المعركه في حالات سابقه كان هناك مواجهه
قويه او
تصريحات ناريه بين قياده مجموعه وعدد من
الوحدات العسكريه الروسيه بما في ذلك على
وجه الخصوص
المظليين الروس ولكن التبعات كانت محدوده
للغايه بالنسبه الى العمليات الميدانيه
اما اذا ما عدنا خطوه الى الوراء دائما
نقول ان الشركات الامنيه والعسكريه الخاصه
مفيده لفتره وجيزه ومحدوده من اجل ادي
الثغرات على سبيل المثال الاستعانه بعدد
من المتخصصين وهذه التجربه تلجا اليها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولجات في
العراق وفي افغانستان منذ سنوات ولكن لسوء
الحظ عندما يحلون المشكلات على المدى قصير
يخلقون مشاكل كبيره للجيش على الامد
البعيد الجيوش النظاميه يمكنها ان تعمل
ولكن لا يمكنها ان تعمل بالتوازي مع هذه
المجموعات لان الرواتب التي تدفع
للمنضوينا في هذه الشركات الخاصه هي اكبر
بكثير من رواتب الجيوش قبل ان نستكمل
النقاش مع ضيوفنا لنتعرف اكثر على هذه
المجموعه مجموعه بغنه كيف نشات اين اين
تنتشر
بانها شركه عسكريه خاصه ويراها اخرون اقرب
ما تكون الى مجموعه روسيه عسكريه شبه
رسميه فهي وحده تتمتع وفق صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز بالاستقلاليه وتتبع وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يعتقد ان مؤسسها هو ضابط سابق في
القوات الخاصه وحملت اسمه السري فاغنر
لكنها الان مملوكه لرجل الاعمال
ويعرف باسم الطباخ بوتين لادارته شركه
كونكورد المنظمه لحفلات الاستقبال
بالكرملين وتضم مزيجا من مقاتلين يقدمون
خدماتهم مقابل المال بدات العمل لاول مره
مع ضم روسيا لشبه جزيره القرم في عام 2014
ونفذت هجمات في شرق اوكرانيا يقول مسؤولون
بريطانيون ان عدد مقاتل فاجندر ارتفع من
نحو الف الى ما يقرب من عشرين الف مقاتل
في اوكرانيا اي نحو 10% من اجمالي القوات
الروسيه على الارض افتتح بريكوجين اول في
مدينه سام بطرسبورغ الروسيه وقال في بيانه
مهمه مركز فاجنر هي توفير بيئه مريحه
لتوليد افكار جديده بغيه تحسين القدره
الدفاعيه لروسيا وتحسين القدره الدفاعيه
لروسيا لا يمكنه اخفاء حقيقه الاتهامات
بارسال مسلحها الى عده دول في امريكا
اللاتينيه وافريقيا وتنفيذ ما توصف
بالعمليه القذره في مناطق النزاعات
المختلفه ففي سوريا انتشرت فاجنر لدعم
نظام السوري منذ 2016 خصوصا حول حقول
النفط في دير الزور وخطفت الاضواء اكثر
بعد مقتل عدد من افرادها في غاره امريكيه
عام 2018
وتنشط المجموعه في ليبيا منذ 2016 وتدعم
القوات المواليه للواء المتقاعد خليفه
حفتر وكشف تقرير سري للامم المتحده وجود
اكثر من 1000 من عناصرها لكن التقارير
اخرى تقدرهم بالالاف
كما تنتشر ميليشيا فاجنر في جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى لحراسه مناجم الذهب
والالماس وتشير تقارير الى وجود لها في
مدغشقر وموزمبيق والسودان وكان اخر انتشار
لها في مالي بعد انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه
من هناك
في في موسكو الكل الان ينتظر ما سيقوله
بوتين ما توقعاتك في هذا الشان
ش
انه كل شيء سوف يكون على اساس القانون في
دولتنا منذ البدايه وفي الجيش خاصه كل
القرارات التي سوف يتخذها السيد بوتين سوف
تكون على الاساس القانوني لن يكون هناك اي
اعمال بشكل خاص من جماعات صغيره خاصه
بتهديدات لهذا الشيء غير مسموح به واكد
انه حسب وجهه نظري وجهه النظر الرسميه في
وزاره الدفاع كل ما يحدث هي عمليات
استفزازيه تصب في مصلحه العدو ولكن كل شيء
يجب ان يعود للقانون لذلك الان هناك دعوه
قضائيه واعتقد ان في الوقت القريب سوف
يكون هناك وقائع في التحقيقات وعلى اساس
هذه الدلائل سوف يقوم الرئيس بوتين
بالقرارات المتناسبه مع القوانين ان
الصلاحيات عند الرئيس متوفره لهذا ولكن هل
هناك احتمال
لتصادم مباشر عسكري بين الجيش الروسي
وفاجنر
اعطاء مورنا هذا شيء ممكن توقعه فقط نظريا
على اساس
الفهم من هم المتواجدين في قوات فاجنر
وعندما تعرف قواتنا العسكريه التي اخدم
انا في صفوفها منذ ثلاثين سنه انا لا
استطيع ان اتصور هذا السيناريو ولكن اذا
حدث هذا
هذه ماساه ضخمه ولكن النظر في هذا
السيناريو كشيء واقعي لا استطيع ان ارى
هذا
لا يرى ذلك ولكن هل تراه انت لواء فايز
الدويري
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه نحن في طعمه تصريحات
اخطر ما في الامر هو الاشاره الى تحرك هذه
القوات باتجاه الروستوس ولكن لا بد من
اتخاذ اجراء من قبل الكرملين يسبق اي حدوث
اشتباك او اصطدام
في النهايه لا يمكن للرئيس بوتين ان ياخذ
بيد بريجوجن بمواجهه
وزير الدفاع
ورئيس الاركان الذين يمثلون الجانب
العسكري قد يكون هناك نوع من التفاهمات
الوسطيه لكنها لن تعطي بريجوجن ذلك العظمه
وذلك التاثير بانه هو من يقرر مصير وزير
دفاع او رئيس اركان لا اتوقع ان يكون هناك
يعني او احتماليه ان يحدث قدام تبقى
محدوده جدا لماذا لانه اذا حدث اي صدام
فكاننا مجازا اقول ان بريجوجن حرق مراكبه
وعاد الان لا يقوى على الحراك لانه دخل في
صدام مفتوح مع المؤسسه الوطنيه الاولى
وبالتالي وقد يصعد في التصريحات ويحاول ان
يستفز من اجل تسجيل نقاط لكن لا اتوقع ان
تذهب به الامور الى ان يدخل في مواجهه
مسلحه مع الجيش الروسي في انتظار اتضاح
الصوره سيد هل ترى ان القيادات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه مع القيادات العسكريه في
النيتو ربما ربما مدعوه الى اعاده النظر
في الوضع العسكري ككل في ضوء ما جرى
الليله
لست متاكدا مما اذا كانت الامور التي حصلت
تؤثر على المنحل اوسع والاشمل للامور
لاننا نتحدث عن قوات روسيه الان في موقع
الدفاع الان لكي تحافظ على الاراضي التي
احتلتها في الاشهر القليله الماضيه
وشاهدنا ايضا
تقاتل او عدم اتفاق في الاراء بين الاوساط
المختلفه للجيش الروسي منذ بدايه هذه
العمليه وبالتالي لست متاكدا من تاثير ما
يحصل الان على السياسه العامه للنيتو
ولاوكرانيا النقطه الاساسيه هي بالنسبه
الى السيد
هل يتحدث الان ويعبر عن افكار الان
مرتبطه بشكل متزايد
بالاتجاه القومي المحافظ من ضمن الاتحاد
الروسي هذا هو السؤال على كل التصعيد الذي
نتطرق اليه منذ بدايه هذه التغطيه سبقته
تصريحات اخرى غير مسبوقه من رئيس شركه
فاجنر
اتهم فيها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بخداع
الرئيس والشعب الروسيين وذلك بالترويج ان
اوكرانيا تتحالف مع النيتو لمهاجمه روسيا
وقال ان المبررات التي تم الاستناد لها
لغزو اوكرانيا منذ البدء كانت مبنيه على
اكاذيب
تحاول وزاره الدفاع خداع الرئيس والشعب
الروسي بالترويج ان اوكرانيا تتحالف مع
الناتو لمهاجمه روسيا والعمليه الخاصه
انطلقت لاسباب مختلفه كليا
قال كذلك ان الجيش الروسي بدا يتراجع في
خرسون وسابروجيا تحت وطاه الهجمات
الاوكرانيه وهاجم قاده وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ملتهما اياهم باخفاء معلومات عن
تطور المعارك ميدانيه
ابتداء من اليوم شرع الجيش الروسي في
التراجع في خرسون وزابولوجيا تحت وطاه
الهجوم الاوكراني نحن نغرق بدمائنا ولا
احد يمدنا بتعزيزات القياده غائبه قاده
وزاره الدفاع يقومون بخداع الرئيس الذي
يتلقى تقارير لا تعكس ما يجري على ارض
الواقع هناك روايتان ما يجري في الميدان
وما يتم اعلام الرئيس به
سيد فاديكارو في موسكو بغض النظر عن كل
شيء هل يمكن ان نرى في مقاله
مدعاه للمؤسسه العسكريه
لمراجعه بعض الخيارات والقرارات العسكريه
الحقيقه السيد بوتين القائد الاعلى
والاداره العسكريه دائما
ينظرون بمرونه لقراراتهم
ويقومون بحل الاخطاء بطريقه عقلانيه اذا
كان هناك اخطاء اما بالنسبه لبدايه
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه فلقت اضطررنا
للقيام بها لسبب الذي هو المكان لدينا
معلومات اننا اذا ما قمنا بالعمليه
العسكريه
العسكريه الخاصه لكانه الهجمات الاوكرانيه
في الدمباص لكانت ان تبدا بعد ايام قليله
ثم كانوا سوف يهجموا على القرم التي تعتبر
مواقع روسيه وهذا شيء معتمد في الدكتور
الروسي وما كنا لنسمح بهذا واذا كان احد
يقوم باخطاء فانهم يقومون بتصحيح هذه
الاخطاء ولا نعيدها
وانتم ترون هذا جيدا حسب الاوضاع
المتواجده على الجبهات نحن نتقدم ونقوم
بالهجوم في بعض الجبهات مساله المعنويات
سيد بطرفيس في في جناب مساله المعنويات
لدى اي جيش مساله مهمه جدا كل ما جرى
الليله كيف يمكن ان ينعكس على
ذهنيه ومعنويات
المقاتل الروسي في اوكرانيا
اعتقد
انه من المستحيل ان نتوقع بكل سهوله وبشكل
منطقي
الاتجاه الذي سوف تذهب به معنويات الجيش
الروسي يجب ان نتوخى الدقه الان في هذه
المرحله القوات الاوكرانيه لديها معنويات
مرتفعه خصوصا بعد النجاحات التي حققتها
العمليه المضاده بالنسبه الى المعنويات
الروسيه هي اضعف مما كانت عليه بالمقارنه
مثلا مع الاسابيع الماضيه ولكن اذا ما
تغيرت الامور اذا ما زادت الانتقادات
الموجهه لكيفيه سير العمليات اذا ما تراجع
الدعم للقوات المسلحه قد نشهد تراجع ا على
الامد البعيد للمعنويات بين اوساط الجنود
الروسي نخدم معك باختصار لواء فايز
الدويري هل تعتقد بان ما جرى سيؤدي في
النهايه الى قطيعه كامله ونهائيه بين
بوتين
يعني اتوقع انه لابد من وضع اطار جديد اذا
ارادوا الابقاء على قوات فاجنر يجب ان يتم
تعديل منظومه القوانين التي انشات بناء
عليها
واعتقد ان
مستقبل بريجوجن قد بدا يتلاشى
والهاله التي وضعها حول نفسه بدات تخفو
هكذا اقرا المشهد لانه تجاوز الخطوط
الحمراء فيما يتعلق بالمؤسسه العسكريه
اولا
وبالدور الناظم للرئيس بوتين في اداره
العمل السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
جناب العقيد الكسندر
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
ولضيفنا من موسكو فزيلي
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي والضابط
الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي
كانت هذه اذا متابعتنا المباشره للتصعيد
غير المسبوق بين مجموعه فاجنر والقياده
العسكريه الروسيه تغطيتنا متواصله على راس
الساعه في جوله منتصف الليل وفيها نتابع
اخر التطورات خاصه وان واضح ان مازال
مستمرا في تصريحاته في امان الله
[موسيقى]